okay so like I just woke up right like
what did my whole morning process just
look as soon as I woke up because I
jumped up and I got on Twitter and I was
like good morning Rob poor like and then
then like as I was typing that I
remember the Carol Danvers trailer
dropped and I was like holy [ __ ] do the
Captain Marvel trailer so I was like
okay like I'm so ready for this thing so
so I get like I jump onto YouTube and I
start checking YouTube I don't see
anything all I see are those crappy
fan-made trailers where people try to
trick people and so like I'm like okay
because it says like nine months ago and
I'm like all right so that shit's false
and so I'm just like sitting there
waiting so I go through my whole morning
process and then I jump on YouTube again
and it says like uploaded nine minutes
ago the Captain Marvel trailer and I was
like just so like I play that [ __ ] dude
that trailer though oh my god dude 1990s
nostalgia
Nick Fury's got both eyes Coulson's got
like a like a faux hawk kind of you know
I'm just like I'm like man like you
Colson man like you looking a little too
old for that look but I understand
they're trying to make you look young
but come on man
they say Hollywood you know you got it
you got to look like your age are you
don't want to end up looking like Joan
Rivers where you just use you just kind
of look kind of look like somebody with
like beat you in the face with putty
like you know you don't you don't want
to look like that so so I'm looking I'm
watching this whole thing and then like
like it looks cool like it's kind of
what I expected in terms of the scenes
and stuff like that but like it looks
like two big things are happening here
one we're getting Carol Danvers binary
and then we're getting then we're
getting like Secret Invasion
dude okay okay so so I don't know which
one to start with first because they're
both badass
okay let start with binary so here was
the deal
back in the 1970s Marvel had a whole
bunch of anthology books and the reason
why was because in the 1960s they gave
us like Spider Man and Thor and the
Avengers and Captain America came back
in iron man incredible so on but the
x-men was the first big flop of Marvel
in the 1960s and then in the mid-late
1960s like a lot of people don't know
that x-men like like people did not like
the x-men the way that Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby wrote them so after that Marvel
was like okay so maybe we've run our
course in terms of just like throwing
out a whole bunch of solo books maybe we
should be more conservative and how we
publish our books and so they sort of go
they they did what DC used to do back in
the late 1930s in the early 1940s and
they started releasing an anthology
books now what our anthology books
anthology books are
basically a comic book where you have a
whole bunch of stories in that book and
so that's what Marvel started releasing
things like Marvel presents and Marvel
premiere and Marvel superheroes is so on
and so forth now in Marvel Comics at the
time you had a character named Marvel it
was ma r ma R - ve ll I'm pretty sure it
was and then there's like there's like
genus Val and so on and so forth which I
really really hope we get file avail and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe one day do
my love I love Ella's quasar was on the
marriage anyway um so so so marvel at
the time was a Kree soldier who was sent
to earth I think for the purpose of
deciding whether they could be captured
or something like that and then like
meThe your superheroes and then became a
good guy and turned against the Kree
army and so that led to a conflict like
a bunch of conflict between himself and
his his general enemy named Yan Rock now
eventually that comes to a head when
you're on rod shows up on earth at Cape
Canaveral or caged Citadel I could never
remember which one because one of them
was the place that magneto attacked
which I want to say was came to Citadel
it was a place magneto attacked in his
first encounter with the x-men and the
other one is where Carol Danvers was
stationed at as an Air Force pilot I
want to say she was in Cape Canaveral
and magneto attacked Kate's Citadel but
regardless of the case uh Carol Danvers
is enamored by Captain Marvel she's
watching you know by by Marvel she's
watching all this stuff unfold and she's
exposed to the sight magnetron which is
basically a wishing machine and she's
like I wish I had I wish I was equal to
Marvel more or less is what happens and
site magnetron blames her human
physiology with Kree physiology and she
goes forward as Miss Marvel and she was
drawn to be like a very luscious looking
character to attract boys but she was
also really empowering for a lot of
young girls now this goes to like the
whole of the 1970s right and and as time
progresses like the x-men just keep
getting more and more popular and so
it's kind of like okay
like what like what do we do like how
can we make her character Amy because
interest in her just began to drop off
for a variety of reasons because people
like the x-men story because her stories
are more like adventurous and there were
more you know getting out there and and
you know deal dealing with a lot more
tangible real world things like feminism
but people wanted to see the x-men like
like Chris Claremont style of
storytelling across the entire Marvel
landscape which he has so many riders
Yemen where Thomas
had all these different guys who were
run into them stories and so carol
danvers began to drop off an interest so
they said okay well how do we make her
interesting will them throw her on to
the x-men like they were on to the x-men
team and so what happens is Chris
Claremont takes over because he wrote
the captain he brought the Miss Marvel
line of comics at the tail end and then
took her and threw her on the x-men team
and eventually he writes a story where
she's kidnapped by a by an alien race
called a brood which doesn't really
matter but what the brood do is they
modify her genes so she can tap into the
power of a white dwarf star what does
that mean it means that you can do
whatever she wants to do because Chris
Claremont says the story calls for it
and so basically she she becomes a new
character named binary it's binary
she is broken like dude she is she's
she's o-p-s hell she can fly through
space without oxygen she has cosmic
awareness she can channel cosmic
energies I don't you could do like all
just all this crazy [ __ ] she acts like
minor reality manipulation it's crazy
like all the powers that she has she
just becomes like super broken and so
from there Chris Claremont was like okay
so let's take the next step let's like
merge her with rogue so you get like
Avengers uh you know you don't you get
yeah Avengers
no no x-men Avengers annual number ten
or x-men annual number ten I think it
was a vendor's annual number ten yeah
because Avengers 200 is the one where a
guy gives birth to himself through Carol
Danvers don't ask so so so anyways so
rogue shows up like it's do that all
dude it's the most beasts [ __ ] ever
rogues showed to man i'ma tell you
something rogue meets meets mystique and
Mystique's like I'm your mom and rogues
like whatever
so mystics like good The Avengers
mansion and like steal the hammer Thor
or some [ __ ] like that and she does does
she also do rogue rolls into Avengers
mansion and just crushes everyone and
then like tastes like touches Thor and
then becomes worthy and takes is him and
just like goes forward is like rogue
Ford it's the most beasts [ __ ] ever but
anyway she ends up grabbing Carol
Danvers he latches on to Carol Danvers
for too long and then upstarts or a part
of Carol Danvers consciousness and that
leads to a whole story arc with rogue
where she's wild she's like constantly
fighting herself finding like the Miss
Marvel personnel persona inside of her
own mind but like Harold Danvers
eventually like went back to be normal
and then lost her like she lost her
binary connection or whatever it is and
then just kind of like you know what
forward is a recurrent or if you guys
are interested in Carol Danvers go read
the Kelly sued iconic run
of Captain Marvel because that's when
she actually becomes Captain Marvel up
to that point she was always Miss Marvel
or Carol Danvers and so like she adopts
the Captain Marvel moniker going forward
from there you don't really know
anything before that you can just pick
up with Kelly sue the conex run but uh
but it's like the best run of her
character ever do not read Civil War 2
because then you'll hate her so so like
just read Kelly soon aquatics run and
then just go forward from there now
having said that Secret Invasion is what
I'm the most interested about that
that's what I'm the most interested in
because Secret Invasion was absolutely
it was it was do Secret Invasion was so
cool so in the Secret Invasion storyline
that takes place after the first Civil
War right but like the the things that
led to it take place long before the
first Civil War so a Marvel Comics you
have a secret group called the
Illuminati so you so it's basically
black panther a name was Submariner it
was Charles Xavier then became Captain
America during the events of no no was
it that was no Captain America I can
never remember because Jonathan Hickman
changed that can Captain America I think
was originally part of the Illuminati
and that no no he wasn't on it was
Charles Xavier who was originally part
of that they've brought Captain America
and during the incursions during the
collapse of the multiverse and then like
all the Illuminati agree they would have
to start destroying planets and Captain
America said no that's not okay so
Doctor Strange wiped his mind and then
sit him forward and then eventually he
learns the truth about what's going on
it was one of the coolest things ever
likes like like Tony Stark is like he's
like I'm sorry Steve and he says he says
like he's like Steven do it and and sees
like what and the see mr. Randall like
dr. strange has just learned like Steve
Rogers like what are you talking about
it dr. strange is like I'm sorry like
I'm sorry Steve and then just wipes his
mind and so he's just he's just laying
there totally unaware of anything that
was going on the coolest thing ever it
was it was you're Tony Stark was such a
dick and so so anyway um so so there was
a point where the Illuminati so it was
like this like black panther it's well
they met in Wakanda black panther didn't
want to be part of it originally but he
ended up joining in any way during the
incursion
but you had the yeah Charles Xavier he
had Professor X you had a Tony Stark
Iron Man you had Doctor Strange you had
a name of the Submariner anyway the idea
was they were they were gonna operate
behind the scenes and they were going to
basically make sure that they always had
all their
together in Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four they were always gonna
make sure that they shared information
for any one particular event so the
whole plan would always be safe and so
what they do is they travel to the
scroll home world of scrubs and they're
like because because what you had was a
priest wrote war it was a war between
the Kree in the scrolls that almost
destroyed Earth and so they traveled to
the scroll homeworld and they're like
look do not bring your [ __ ] to this
world like do not bring your problems
here all right like stayed there like
you stay there you do your thing do not
bring your problems here
and so the scrolls are just like but
like who the hell do you think you are
though and so like they kidnap the
Illuminati right and maybe they start
analyzing their genes you know and all I
kind of get stuff and then like that
like the Illuminati have no idea that
happens they just wake up and they're
like well we got to get out of here we
got to escape and they successfully
escape when they leave
all right this fast-forward some time
when Galactus shows up and destroys the
scroll homework like absorbs the the you
know the life energy of the Skrull
homeworld to sustain himself and so the
scrolls flee because they're like okay
well now it's manifest destiny we have
to go to earth so like we're gonna we're
gonna take over the planet Earth so they
start basically start replacing earth
superheroes with Scroll replicants and
eventually like this this is discovered
in two ways the first person to discover
it is Nick Fury when he realizes there's
a human woman that he's talking to he's
kind of bang him for a little bit
that's a scroll and so he's he's
underground at the time this is this is
old-school white Nick Fury it's not
Samuel Jackson Nick Fury so Nick Fury
realizes what's going on he goes
underground
then he assembles the secret warriors so
he brings in like Daisy Johnson quake
and like all these other other
characters and then and then it is
Elektra it's the character as a
character of Elektra who's somebody or
who it is somebody realizes maybe it's
Wolverine somebody realizes Electra's a
scroll and so that's when the
superheroes begin to realize that like
not all the superheroes are actually
superheroes and so finally like the
events of Secret Invasion come to a head
and it's like all the actual superheroes
meet they're their superhero replicants
from the scroll this is massive huge
battle Deadpool's involved because of
course is Deadpool and like Deadpool
Deadpool technically saves the day and
sends the information back to earth on
how to defeat the scrolls and then
Norman Osborn the Green Goblin
intercepts it and the Norman Osborn is
just like yeah so like hey guys I know
how to beat the scrolls well at this
time Civil War is done right like the
Civil War conflict is done the
superhuman Registration Act went through
the bad guy
one and Tony Stark is director of shield
and so when that half is when Norman
Osborn shows up and says hey I know how
to beat the scrolls and then defeats
them all then like the government looks
to Tony Stark it says how could you not
have known this happen like how could
you not know that's such a huge
percentage of the Earth's population
where sprawl replicants they're like
you're a terrible leader of shield so
they kick him out right Tony Stark gets
kicked out his director of shield and
Norman Osborn gets stepped in like like
or they they say okay Norman Osborn
because for whatever reason you can't
trust the Green Goblin
so like Norman Osborn you're the new
director she had what is no reward do
dis Mandelson he shuts it down
he's like shield is now done instead I'm
gonna create a hammer and in place of
hair like like with hammer I'm gonna do
a bad guys do what just try to conquer
the world this leads into a whole
publication house called Dark Reign and
it is like the coolest thing ever
the x-men leave Westchester in New York
and they do they go to utopia off the
coast of San Francisco and like all the
superheroes go underground like
everybody's part of the Secret Avengers
now like they're all part of Captain
America's Secret Avengers team and then
like like like Norman Osborn takes all
the villains and turns them into the
superheroes so like dating the son of
Wolverine becomes a noob Wolverine and
like there's one character I came over
who it is who becomes the new know he
becomes a new Iron Man it becomes iron
patriot Ares the God of War replaces
Thor I think it is or like century joins
us team you have is it
bullseye replaces daredevil like it's
really cool in terms of like how this
whole thing unfold that goes on a dark
gray which is a whole whole different
discussion but it looks like it's gonna
be badass like this movie looks like
it's setting the stage for Secret
Invasion which I really want to see so
like I'm in that trailer that's for that
trailer looks so beast and dude can we
all just agree
brie Larson looks amazing as Carol
Danvers damn brie Larson like I didn't
know she would look that great she looks
amazing as Carol Danvers like like she's
getting a modern-day costume would that
make sense I mean you know I don't
understand why people got pissed off
about why her costume like like in the
pictures wasn't like the ones you see
now that's like getting angry because
they show you like the Iron Man suit
marked one instead of like the mark two
never the March 3 or whatever is like
well of course it's the first suit she
was wearing that's I mean the like like
yeah do you think like do you think like
she was gonna
like half the Captain Marvel see
Thomasson it took her like 40 years in
mobile Commons to get that thing but
anyway so so yeah I'm really excited
like I'm very very excited and I'm I'm
I'm very very high I think the movies
gonna be badass but let me know you guys
think that in the comment section let me
know you guys think because it looks
like it's gonna it looks like it's gonna
be sweet it looks like it's gonna be be
pretty awesome
um but yeah if Carol Danvers has the
power of binary well I wouldn't say
she's as powerful as Stannis with the
Infinity Gauntlet I'd say she's pretty
damn close to that version now if we're
talking about Stannis with the Infinity
Gauntlet and Marvel Comics and all it
would take someone like the molecule man
like it would take them if it was it was
if it was stano's with you with the
power of the Infinity gamma from the
comics if they had that version in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe all it would
take somebody like like yeah it would
take somebody like the molecule man I
want a Reese to stop him like like you
would and and then like yeah it was like
three retcon like if it was if it was
Owen Reese away here where Julie was
yeah he would just be like Endor done
now like that would that would be it
like dude be like a wave of his hand and
it's like and now you're finished Thanos
so I'm gonna go home like that this see
people understand how powerful some of
the people in Marvel Comics are your
molecule man was insane that's that's
exactly how that would have gone down if
it was like 1987 molecule man yeah he
would have walked in like saddle-sore
been like I have the infinite ego have
absolute power and molecule lands like
whatever man like I could beat the hell
out of you and be home in time for
cornflakes and just like like wave his
hand and then like Santos is like what
happened and molecule man's like I took
your power away so I'm gonna go home now
and everybody have a good day and let me
know if you guys need anything
Percy funny anyway guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you guys
are new here to come this explained
Richie you guys to the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like I apologize for my morning look and
I will catch you all later purse